chez nous les choses ont plutôt tendance
à s'améliorer ce soir mais les
inondations ont fait beaucoup de dégâts
sandra smit et didier beaumont ont
survolé les alpes de haute provence et
la côte d'azur
plusieurs villages sont encore isolés
une seule route mène à colmar les alpes
la départementale 908 sectionné par le
verdon en six points différents
le village située à 1200 mètres
d'altitude dans les alpes de haute
provence reste donc inaccessible même
les secours par hélicoptère sont arrivés
très tard le mauvais temps empêcher tout
survol de la zone
colmar les half a été prise au piège non
seulement par la crue du verdon mais
aussi par celle de la lance le cours
d'eau a même balayé le cimetière du
village et emporté des tombes
les habitants évacués n'ont pu que
regarder des mètres d'eau défilé nouveau
roi le compte de la force pour arracher
des portes pour écraser des congélateurs
les locaux de la gendarmerie et des
pompiers ont aussi été endommagés pour
le village le plan sexe déclenché ce
matin est arrivé trop tard la préfecture
très tôt à hauteur du sort on a encore
rappelé je pense qu'à 10 ne se sont pas
aperçus des problèmes que colmar passé
je suis je suis je suis déçu nous
n'avons pas déclencher le plan orsec
pendant la nuit parce que sannois
n'aurait servi à rien ça n'aurait
apporté aucun secours supplémentaires
3000 habitants dont beaucoup de
vacanciers restent bloqués ce les
secours terrestres vont circuler sur une
piste un scénario qui se répète dans
d'autres villages du département plus
bas dans les alpes-maritimes le niveau
du var a baissé mais l'autoroute a8 est
toujours impraticable du côté de
l'aéroport de 10,1 aéroports paralysés
au moins jusqu'à mardi matin
privés d'eau et d'électricité les deux
terminaux sont inondées sans
électronique l'enregistrement des
passagers n'est pas possible
le deuxième aéroport de france est
totalement asphyxiée